tier lists have been a staple of youtube
for a few years now
at this point you can find a ranking of
just about anything
tier zoo was the first channel i saw to
combine the format with
science and learning but it's already
spread into
physics and maths as well for example
andrew dotson recently did a ranking of
his favorite physics equations
today i thought it would be time to
create an ultimate mathematical shapes
tier list
i've got a non-rigorous point system to
give each shape
a fair chance at that coveted s-tier
position
so each object will be judged on
symmetry
singularities the significance in other
disciplines outside of mathematics
how difficult it is to define or create
and the aesthetics for aesthetics we're
really asking
does this shape deserve its own mood
board on pinterest
now that's of course going to be
subjective but it's worth including
aesthetics as a criteria because
it's kind of important to math the
beauty of the shape
may indicate that we've got some kind of
elegant solution
or at least to help inspire interest in
the topic
so let's start with a nice simple shape
the common sphere
i'll be using the software surfer to
model some of these shapes
this algebraic surface is as old as it
gets
it is perfectly symmetric which makes it
awesome to work with
but at the same time it might be a bit
boring and uninspiring
because it looks the same in all
directions
however this hasn't stopped the sphere
from becoming a major player in other
disciplines
you see it in art and sports and
engineering all the time
and even in astrophysics for things like
planets
and even black holes spheres are very
effective
for modeling all sorts of things
probably because the sphere is
very easy to understand aesthetics wise
the sphere might not be the most
interesting shape
but because of its heroic performance in
all sorts of disciplines
and how easy it is to construct i think
that b-tier
is more than deserved next up is another
classic
the mobius strip it's a two-dimensional
object with only one side
and one edge that can be embedded in a
three-dimensional space
there are no notable things to say about
its symmetry or
singularities but just like with the
sphere
where the mobius strip shines is in its
applications to other disciplines
surprisingly there are actually some
applications of this strange little
shape
one of them is that in the days of
industrialization
a lot of factories had one central
engine to provide
rotational energy to operate all of the
machines
a common thing was to use flat leather
belts
to transmit the central power some were
instead given a half twist before
joining the ends
and this would allow for the wear to be
evenly distributed
over both sides of the belt you can make
a mobius strip pretty easily yourself
just take a long piece of paper give it
a twist
and glue the ends together if you start
at any
point and draw along the strip you end
up where you started
in mathematics we call a shape with a
property like this
non-orientable since you can't really
define
an up or a down on a surface like this i
think the simplicity of being able to
create
such an interesting shape makes it very
intriguing and
worthy of an a tear spot
now this next crazy critter is the bath
sex dick
which i recently made an entire video
about it's going to belong in s-tier
because it's got very interesting
symmetry record-breaking singularities
and an intriguing history it is one of
the world record surfaces
since it holds the record for having the
largest number of singularities
for a polynomial of degree 6. that
record that it holds
is 65 singularities and it was proven
that it can never be beaten
that 66 singularities isn't possible
now there are some other members of the
world record squad
and they ought to join it in here as
well so
we have the toggliati quintic which
holds the record
for a polynomial of degree 5 and that
record is
31 singularities i think they belong one
tier below the bath sextic
since their record is for a lower degree
then likewise we have the humor aquatic
which holds the record for a polynomial
of degree
4 and that record it holds is 16
singularities
i'll put that one in b here and then
we'll have the kayleigh cubic
another world record surface this time
of degree
3 coming in with four singularities
and getting placed in c tier the next
one
is also a record holder it's the double
cone coming in with one singularity
for degree two i talk about this one a
bit as well in my video about the bath
sex stick
you can really see that prominent
singularity in the middle of the shape
this shape is also quite interesting in
special relativity in physics
as you might have seen it in something
called a light cone
it shows the causal future and the past
you can think of the singularity in the
middle as an event in space time
and all other events inside the double
code
can have a causal relationship with that
first event
everything outside the code would be too
far away
to have any impact or to be impacted by
the original event in space time and
this angle of the cone
is governed by the speed of light that's
a very interesting application
but because the record this one holds is
not as impressive as some of the other
records we've seen
it's going to sit in seat here for now
i've got two more shapes to quickly
mention here
which also currently hold world records
but perhaps not for long
these are the lab septic and the indras
optic these currently hold records
for seven and eighth degree polynomials
although these records haven't been
proven to be
unbeatable in the way that our other
record holders were
for the bath sextic we've proven that
you can never
have more than 65 singularities but here
for the septic and this optic it's very
feasible that
someone might be able to find a shape
which will beat it
for that reason they're both going to be
banished to deter
let's see what we can do next we have
gauss's
bell surface the surface might look
unspectacular at first
since there are no interesting points
that really stand out
no singularities but don't underestimate
this gem of mathematics
it is used all the time in statistics
and
is the foundation of the normal
distribution
furthermore what's very interesting is
that the formula
defining the surface shows a really nice
connection between the fundamental
constants
pi and e this one's difficult to rank
because the aesthetics are
lacking a bit and the competition is
harsh but we'll place them here in
c tier next up we can do the taurus
or you might like to call it a doughnut
it is a rotational symmetric
shape of genus one since it has one
hole and this shape is often brought up
when talking about the topic of topology
everything with one hole is said to be
topologically equivalent to a taurus
and a classic example is a coffee mug
with a handle
or a drinking straw of course its
applications are very wide from
hair ties to rings to edible donuts
or even pool toys it has vast
applications and because of that we're
going to put it in b
tier next we have a shape which
is a close relative of one that we've
already seen
this is the klein bottle and it's very
similar to
the mobius strip since both surfaces
are non-orientable the klein bottle also
has
only one surface but unlike the strip
the two-dimensional bottle can't be
embedded in three dimensions
it always looks like it intersects
itself when in reality
it doesn't you might have noticed this
shape in my profile picture here on
youtube
the beanie that i wear is actually a
klein bottle hat
that i made by knitting it although of
course
it's not an accurate klein bottle
since that can't exist in 3d if you see
the way it
intersects that wouldn't happen if we
had the luxury of
a fourth spatial dimension unfortunately
making nice hats and glass bottles might
be the limit of
applications that i know about for the
klein bottle to
the world outside mathematics but the
klein bottle definitely deserves to be
ranked alongside the mobius strip
up here in a tier especially because
if you actually were to split a klein
bottle in half
what you would have would be two mobius
strips
this little twisty boy is called the
trey foil knot
and it does seem to be the poster child
for not theory
it is named after the three leaf clover
the tray foil plant and it has some nice
triangular sort of symmetry to it the
knot is one continuous loop
and easy enough to make yourself using a
string
i also happen to have this sculpture
lying around which
is another example of this kind of knot
so clearly it's going to rank pretty
high on aesthetics if they're literally
selling it
as a decoration i don't have a great
deal of knowledge and not
theory but apparently this is the first
non-trivial knot
and one of the reasons why not theory is
so interesting
is that it seems to have many
applications in biology and chemistry
for things like proteins and dna that
are knotted in some
sense i'm going to rank it in b tier for
now
it's got some points for aesthetics some
points for a possible usefulness even
though i might not totally understand
how this knot is useful
but it is still a fairly basic shape
we're back to a heavy hitter with the
next one
flams paraboloid this one's going to get
ranked right up
at ester it doesn't perhaps look that
spectacular
but it is pretty cool this shape mimics
the outside of a black hole
in the space-time called the
short-styled solution
in 1915 when einstein published his
famous field equations of general
relativity
he didn't actually solve them himself
instead a german scientist
named carl schwarzschild found the first
interesting solution
in relativity a space-time containing a
black hole
he calculated this while he was
stationed in russia
during the first world war and sadly he
died not long after his groundbreaking
discovery
he calculated that space-time stops
behaving
normal at some radius this is the inner
circle in the middle now we call this
the event horizon
the surface shows how everything gets
attracted to that circle
and what happens beyond this point is
anyone's guess at the moment
it is amazing to see how clearly general
relativity
predicted the existence of black holes
like this
when no one could imagine this before
this is
a cornerstone of science wrapped up in
one picture
and that's why it deserves to be an
esteer
second to last here we have the
dodecahedron
now this is supposed to represent all
five of the platonic solids
we've all seen them before and they're
so iconic
that they definitely deserve to be
ranked here
all of these solids have some very
special symmetry to them
and in fact these solids define what
symmetries other shapes can have
for example back in my bath sextic video
it was the symmetry of the eye
cosahedron that allowed us to get that
shape
what makes the platonic solids so
special is the uniqueness they have
these shapes are the only options if you
want a polyhedron with identical
faces and corners and the fact that
there are only five
seems quite surprising you see these
shapes of course
a lot in architecture or anywhere really
throughout history
and so considering this a tear is a
fitting spot
and this list would of course not be
complete without at least
one fractal i've chosen to include the
mandelbrot set this relatively new
shape finds its home in complex analysis
and is known for its crazy boundary it
is one of those fractals which
are inherently self-similar meaning that
you can zoom in on the border as much as
you want
and would always end up with the same
thing on screen
there isn't too much to talk about in
terms of symmetry and singularities with
this one
and i'm not sure about any usefulness in
other
scientific fields but it is used a lot
in art
and as i'm sure you can imagine or might
have seen
there are plenty of nice psychedelic
like zooming videos
using this shape plenty of which you can
watch here on youtube
the construction of this shape is
surprisingly simple
and i'm going to explore it using
brilliant who are also a sponsor of this
video
and have been a huge supporter of my
channel i do really like their
explanation
and a lot of their visuals for the
mandelbrot set so let's have a look
at how they say we can define it what
you do
is you start with a complex number call
it z
then if you square that and add it to
itself
look at what you end up with then square
that
and add z to that and keep going like
that forever
you'll notice that one of two things
would happen
either the magnitude explodes up towards
infinity
and in that case the complex number zed
is
not in the mandelbrot set if the
magnitude is bounded
or tends towards zero then the number
zed
is in the mandelbrot set we can ask
ourselves
is the complex number i in the set well
it is because after the first few
iterations we would have
i then minus 1 plus i
then minus i then back to minus one plus
i and this set of answers will repeat
we're in a bit of an
alternating cycle and since we're not
going to
end up going out to infinity the value
of i
is in the mandelbrot set so it will be
plotted somewhere
on that interesting picture another
example is the real number one
with that we would have one then two
then five then 26 and because each
time we're squaring that answer and
adding one to it
we're just going to keep getting larger
and larger until we get to infinity
so one is not in the mandelbrot set
another couple of examples here we have
that minus 2
is in the mandelbrot set whilst minus 2i
is not this here is a full image of the
mandelbrot set
and you can zoom in on parts of the
boundary to see
its chaotic nature the set has a main
cardioid which is this heart-shaped
section here
as well as several attached bulbs and
the position of a number within
either the cardioid or these numbered
bulbs here
tells us something about recursion or i
think the fate of the number
whether it reaches an equilibrium or a
fixed point
i love looking at this fractal because
every piece of it
is loaded with mathematical meaning and
one of the reasons it might be so
appealing
is because you get such a complicated
surface
with a relatively easy mathematical
construction
to this date there are still plenty of
open questions surrounding this set
and it has led to the discovery of many
equally astounding shapes such as the
mandel bulb or the buddha brought it is
pretty legendary so i'm going to put it
up in
s tier let me know what you think of my
ranking i'm sure there will be some that
you disagree with
but it's just for fun and i'm sure there
is also some interesting shapes that
i've left
out because how could i include all of
them in one video
but tell me some of those main ones you
think should be included next time
thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video and if you're interested to
check out their content a bit more they
have courses on mathematics
science including physics astronomy
computer science biology
a lot of interesting stuff you can head
to brilliant.org
tippies and that link will be down in
the description
thanks to my patreon supporters for
making these videos possible
and a special shout out to today's
patron cat of the day
[Music]
maureen